le html va être couplé avec un langage
s'appelle css qui lui va vous permettre
de travailler c'est comme cascades à
vous permettre de travailler en cascade
c'est à dire de mettre de l'animation
dans vos fenêtres et donc dans votre
site vous allez produire des milliers de
nos codes sans vous rendre concentrent
dans le conte et ses milliers de lignes
de code est bien plus voulait produire
et avec une volonté de fer du code de
qualité en faisant pas n'importe quoi du
code propre et bien moins il y aura d'un
cidre ils sont demandeurs d'emploi auto
entrepreneur ou encore étudiants et ne
connaissent rien aux codes ce langage
informatique qui sert de base au
développement ayant six mois ils vont
tout apprendre développeurs web ou de
logiciels ces professions font partie
des plus recherchés si tout se passe
bien
la formation gratuite codeurs web 18
devrait leur permettre de décrocher un
emploi est de découvrir le nouveau monde
du numérique
[Musique]
moi j'ai un profil qui est beaucoup trop
généraliste je n'aurais pas d'emplois
ici sur bonjour
ces profils à centre nombreux pour des
postes limitées donc il me faut vraiment
une expertise et bon j'ai déjà fait un
peu du web auparavant là je suis un
petit peu dans la communication même si
ce n'est pas dans le graphisme
donc ça m'intéresse vraiment de
compléter ce que je sais faire et puis
en revenir à ce que j'ai oublié mois
l'origine je suis graphiste mais
spécialisé prix excusez mon prix ça fait
longtemps que je voudrais prendre le
virage du numérique
aujourd'hui vous communiquer sur tous
les médias et je voudrais profiter de se
transformer en opportunités et parents
femmes formées sur le sujet qui
m'intéresse et qui me permettra de
travailler ou de monter ma structure ce
que je voulais faire comme indépendant
au départ ou de pouvoir travailler dans
la région
les élèves âgés de 20 à 52 ans ont des
niveaux et des profils très différents
particularité de cette formation il se
retrouve seulement une demi journée par
semaine pour faire le point 90% des
cours se passent à distance sans
professeur le travail personnel est donc
très important nous retrouvons lors chez
elle à bourges en pleine séance de
travail
[Musique]
pareil j'ai recommencé à zéro pour que
cela soit bien clair bien car et thé
party du jour et tu l'avais dans quoi tu
m'as mis dans le maine
juni domaine lors échange avec un autre
collègue de la formation bien son micro
des binômes se sont formés ils
s'entraident dans l'apprentissage de ce
nouveau langage
j'ai vraiment patauger au début surtout
que je m'attendais à avoir plus de
facilité que ça c'est pour ça que
j'insiste vraiment sur des idées que le
groupe
c'est ça qui nous sauvent quand on est
perdu maintenant lâché dans une phase où
je patauge sur des petites choses donc
c'est pas gênant ça je peux m'en sortir
donc soit avec l'aide des autres soi
même en fouillant sur internet sur les
ressources qu'on a et c
il y en a d'autres qui vont tellement
vite on a l'impression que qu'il
faudrait déjà savoir faire parce qu'il
montre qu' il s'affaire mais non c'est
pas le cas on peut y aller petit à petit
pas par pas et puis on arrivera au même
endroit et loïc tu peux descendre s'il
te plaît pour l'or le défi professionnel
se double d'un défi personnel
si tu as des livres des médiathèques
tous les dessins avec elle cherche du
travail après avoir élevé ses trois
enfants pendant 14 s'est bien chargé et
l'organisation pêche pour le mans c'est
mon gros point à travailler pour pouvoir
aller plus loin parce que là les
semaines sont encore à ses fins ce
travail est encore assez calme ça va
s'accélérer
120 secondes et pas une de plus un temps
de parole limité à 2 minutes pour la
réunion quotidienne
[Musique]
bienvenue chez enjoy your business
la start-up berruyères casse les codes
du travail - 10 mais il est surtout des
réunions qui ne dépasse pas 30 minutes
je fais des motifs sur les plaquettes
pour jennifer toujours propre texte
après midi et puis après ça va je vais
repasser en fait sur le sur les
documents benjani hier comme l a dit
lucien en a mis en place un nouveau
sprint j'ai avancé sur la partie
statistiques pour qu'elles se chargent
chargement l'onglet parfait la société
développe des solutions numériques pour
améliorer le travail en entreprise
son président a bientôt s'envoler pour
le canada il a créé une filiale à
toronto il ya un an
aujourd'hui on contourne une start up en
fait il faut il faut grossir ou c'est
mourir donc grossir c'est le fait de
pouvoir rayonner le plus possible il
restait franco français c'est pas
possible
l'option être visibles rapidement comme
un outil prêt pour l'export pour être
vendus dans d'autres pays
[Musique]
l'entreprise est partenaire de
l'initiative codeurs web 18
elle accueillera en septembre les élèves
pour un stage de quatre mois
une opportunité à saisir dans ce monde
qui fonctionne en réseau
malheureusement pas pas embaucher tout
le monde c'est un peu la difficulté
qu'on a ça c'est sûr et certain
cela dit faire un stage pertinent
percutant avec des bonnes
recommandations nous c'est quelque chose
qu'on est aussi capable de faire c'est à
dire que j'aimerais bien pouvoir
embaucher derrière ça c'est vrai et si
je peux pas et pas automatiquement les
personnes qui seront venus en stage et
comment faire super s'agit pour avoir
des super recommandations ici les
développeurs maîtrisent bien sûr le code
sur le bout des doigts le code c'est le
langage informatique qu'une machine va
savoir lire mais pour rémy étudiants en
alternance dans cette start up c'est
même bien plus que ça le code c'est
vraiment la matière première pour créer
quelque chose c'est comme si vous voulez
le le pinceau et la tablette d'un
peintre en fait le code en l'humain
[Musique]
on
aussi bien facebook que le gps de la
voiture derrière il ya des gens qui ont
écrit des lignes pour que ça fasse
exactement ça graphiste à paris françois
a récemment emménagé avec sa famille à
bourges cette formation devrait l'aider
à compléter son parcours
moi je suis spécialisé print tout ce qui
est impressions papier depuis pas mal
d'années maintenant et ça fait très très
content que j'aspire à pouvoir
travailler aussi sur le numérique pour
avoir toute la palette parce que
aujourd'hui travailler que sur le papier
c'est c'est comme si je marchais à klaus
pin est en fête ce jour-là il doit créer
son cv en ligne un premier exercice
pratique où chaque signe chaque balise
compte un logiciel l'aide à se repérer
grâce à des couleurs différentes il faut
être précis passion est à l'aise en
anglais
françois est prêt à basculer dans le
numérique le fait de changer de région
parce que ma compagne a trouvé du
travail parle ici ça m'a permis de
j'essaie de transformer ça en nocturne
opportunité pour pouvoir faire ce que
j'avais envie de faire depuis pas mal
d'années sans vraiment me lancer
quartier nord de bourges un ancien
garage sert de locaux à boréale business
ici on prête des applications sur mesure
pour edf ou alloresto romain s'est lancé
dans l'aventuré de la start up à 21 ans
quand il était encore étudiant
notre coeur de métier c'est le
développement informatique de solutions
mobiles et web plutôt orienté e-commerce
donc évidemment le développement c'est
le code c'est notre coeur de métier
[Musique]
ici les développeurs ont tous des
profils différents ingénieurs ou
autodidactes les nouvelles recrues sont
choisis tous ensemble c'est vraiment un
partage de connaissances c'était que la
formation elle ne s'arrête jamais ouais
complètement c'est comme le dit le
directeur technique ici n'a que son bac
et c'est pourtant on va dire celui qui a
le meilleur rendement peut-être dans
l'entreprise enfin ce n'est pas
peut-être là vient de dire ça mais en
tout cas c'est lui qui est aussi capable
d'apprendre et de nous de mener les
choses doivent m'aider à recruter donc
c'est le diplôme ne sert aujourd'hui pas
forcément grand chose en tout cas chez
nous et bien notre état d'esprit
kevin a trouvé la porte d'entrée de
l'emploi il a suivi la formation codeurs
web 36 à châteauroux l'année dernière en
cherchant son stage il a très vite
trouvé un cdi dans cette imprimerie
donc effectivement je suis arrivé ici
justement la fin de la formation pour
trouver des stages qui allait bien et
renault m'a appris tout de suite parce
que justement dans ce rôle entreprises
il savait qu'on avait besoin
d'ordinateur d'informaticiens de
personnes vraiment spécialisés l'aise
dans ce métier là c'est moitié moitié
moitié ordinateur comme toutes les
entreprises industrielles
l'imprimerie est confrontée à la
révolution numérique les commandes
informatiques permettent de tout
réaliser du simple prospectus à cette
horloge en forme de chat il suffit de
s'adapter
la formation de codeurs de kevin a
permis d premièrement de tout
réorganiser le système informatique de
la société
donc on a beaucoup de machines à piloter
kevin a permis de voir de toute l'ue
doté d'un seul endroit donc ce qui nous
permet de gagner du temps donc beaucoup
plus efficace on a là un ascète cette
démarche qui veut que quand on comprend
pas quelque chose on va essayer de voir
comment ça fonctionne pourquoi ça ne
fonctionne pas quand ça ne fonctionne
pas et voilà on sait s'entourer on sait
recherché justement on est une
méthodologie de recherche pour les
problèmes sans s'énerver
sans s'énerver de préférence
bon
attention ce livre n'est pas un livre
comme les autres vincent a copié un
service qui existent déjà à paris et
dans les grandes villes à bourges c'est
lui qui a créé l'application sur
internet coursiers à vélo crêpes salades
ou pizzas sont livrée et payée en
quelques clics à la jolie vrai le client
directement chez lui
donc on se retrouve tout à l'heure c'est
rien c'est la course c'est la course
mais ça y est le compte à rebours est
parti
[Musique]
écoutez
sur son vélo vincent arrive même à être
plus rapide joli scooter ça manquait sur
bourges
les gens sont assez actifs sur la partie
vélo ici avec des associations comme
enchères vélo donc je trouvais ça sympa
et il y avait une demande
livreur la nuit effaceront de start-up
le jour à 24 ans vincent a développé
quatre entreprises dans des domaines
très différents
la cagnotte obsèques coursiers à vélo
elle paco et l'agencé de communication
wind est titulaire d'un master en
risques industriels
ce boulimique des startups à des
journées et des soirées bien remplie
est-ce que vous dormez j'arrive notre
désert pendant et vous rêvez de futures
stars tête quand vous dormez non là je
peux plus j'ai plus de temps dans les
landes rythme voilà je suis au maximum
sur maximum et je me suis j'ai réussi à
organiser comme ça maintenant je ne veux
plus pour l'instant j'attends de voir ce
que ça va donner pour toutes les start
up qui sont mis en route
[Musique]
deuxième certains week end à bourges
c'est le marathon de la bonne idée
cinquante quatre heures pour convaincre
le principe est simple chaque équipe
travaille sur un projet et le présente à
la fin du week-end devant un jury en
quelques minutes les développeurs
confirmés ou non apportent leurs
compétences
l'or a décidé d'y participer les ados
ils sont vraiment dans
quel regard les autres corps sur moi et
ça je pense que ça peut leur parler à
leur idée créer un réseau social pour
les moins de 13 ans qui n'ont pas accès
à facebook accompagner les adolescents
prévenir des dangers et rassurer les
parents le nom réseau est déjà trouvée
il ne reste plus qu'à concrétiser l'idée
c'était une super expérience
j'imaginais pas et bien je pense que je
vais signer pour les prochains le projet
là on le monte très rapidement mais
après si j'avais vraiment le mettre en
oeuvre si on peut mettre en oeuvre grâce
à apprendre plus et engendre est temps
de former mais pour le moment tout de
suite j'apporte au moins mon regard de
maman et puis mes capacités de rédaction
l'apprentissage de ce langage
informatique risque de changer leur vie
et peut être la nôtre des lignes de
codes qui sont autant de lignes de vie
[Musique]